[Musique]
la danse est là c'est la poésie du corps
tous les lundis soir olivier marchand se
retrouve ici dans ce studio de danse des
grands ballets canadiens de montréal
soit même pendant ses étirements ses
compagnes de danse se prépare aux
vestiaires
sent poindre les tutus hockey place
danse thérapie
qui
surtout
andrea d almeida enseigne la thérapie
par la danse et le mouvement depuis
trois ans elle est l'une des rares
spécialistes de cette nouvelle
discipline au canada son groupe des
aînés sont d'abord venus ici pour
s'activer
quand j'ai entendu parler de danse
thérapie je me suis peut-être qu'il ya
là quelque chose qui va m'aider à me
bouger magnen europe 1
[Musique]
bon je vois la danse thérapie comme une
façon nouvelle serre un peu plus
complète d'envisager programme de
gymnastique douce puis quand je dis plus
concrète c'est une interaction avec des
éléments émotionnels avec des éléments
de diên raid la danse thérapie intéresse
le chercheur oui derrère de l'institut
universitaire de gériatrie de montréal
c'est la presse qui sans répondre aux
besoins plusieurs personnes âgées
sédentaires qui se sentent pas du tout
attirée par un programme d'exercices
dans jane s'est passé des jeunes enfants
[Musique]
ces particularités de la danse thérapie
l'expression de soi
les exercices créatif et les mouvements
et pro visite
tout est naturel libre besoin de mettre
la main comme ça où comme ça où comme ça
c'est comme ça nous plaît et sur
baeckeland you move mais de répertoire
comprenant diverses thérapies attend la
posture des talents présentés s'est
placé mi séance ont aussi des visées
thérapeutiques et que du physique au
goût du mouvement balance il 9,5
sibilité une coordination mouvement
moderne qu'est ce que ça vous apporte la
danse thérapie cham d'epargne trois fois
par semaine pendant trois mois
monsieur marchand a participé à l'étude
de louis birere une étude qui vise à
mesurer des bienfaits de la danse
thérapie chez les personnes âgées
ce qui nous intéresse c'est vraiment
l'impact que cela peut avoir sur la
personne dans son entièreté donc son
bien être psychologique sa qualité de
vie son stress son sommet aussi ses
symptômes dépressifs son anxiété et son
bien-être cognitif
on veut voir aussi si on va augmenter
leur mobilité leur qualité marchent par
exemple au niveau de l'équilibré
moi j'ai fait beaucoup de progrès à ce
niveau là se tenir sur une jambe
puis on se s'activent plus on trouve des
ressources à une fois ci des
questionnaires séjour de résultats pour
olivier on a vu deux choses assez
intéressantes au niveau de la mobilité
en fait en votre capacité de marche et
c'est logiquement que vous fassiez un
test de l'échantillonnage de salive à la
maison puis on a vu aussi dans une
mesure physiologique précise qui permet
de documenter le niveau de stress
chronique
donc ça veut dire une amélioration au
niveau du stress des gens qui étaient
avec moi ayant remarqué que j'étais de
plus en plus d'être détendu
[Musique]
des résultats stimulant pour olivier et
pour tout le groupe car le stress est
aussi très présent dans la vie des aînés
la pente devenir non autonomes qui est
toujours dans notre arrière pensée il ya
la peur de manquer dessous soit on s'en
parle en personne vieillissante mais ça
déstresse peau en discussion
une évacuation
ainsi le communiqué je peux pas dire que
j'ai pu de stress ou cas mais ça en a
libéré beaucoup
juste le fait de se faire dire un
mouvement qui qui représente la joie et
je me sais ce que j'ai envie de la jouer
moi il y est c'est venu avec avec l'un
d'entre eux puis les stress est restée
[Musique]
la bonne nouvelle là dedans c'est que la
danse thérapie est aussi sous forme
d'exercices efficace pour améliorer les
fonctions cognitives des améliorations
au niveau de la capacité par exemple de
de contrôler ses efforts mentale de se
concentrer la danse thérapie aiderait
donc à maintenir de bons réflexes et l
esprit alerte pour olivier c'est aussi
une façon de rester jeune et de
développer de l'assurance
[Musique]
bonne idée j'ai du coup mais que pouvais
le danser avec une certaine grâce
elle a dit que j'avais beaucoup
d'inventivité d'alors jeu ça m'a donné
confiance
il a en flexibilité mentale et physique
très fort j'avoue je le revois 80
[Musique]
le fait que ce soit une approche de
groupe s'ajoute aussi un événement de
stimulation j'arrive ici les yeux du
monde qui m'attendent que j'attends est
ce si important celui là le sentiment
d'appartenance
la force du groupe une formule gagnante
pour briser l'isolément des ennemis les
contacts sont moins simples quand on est
vieux que quand on est jeune
en comptant sur trouver comme on ne dit
jamais trop d'occasions d'un de
fraterniser
il fallait libérer l'espèce de ce prix
qui s'installait que la vieillesse
ça va être triste et danser rapidement
apporté cette connivence avec cinq ou
six cents personnes
peut-être ne miraculeux mais bien
prochain le groupe c c'est extra j'ai
des amis je me fais des nouveaux amis
vite ce genre le trousseau etc
centenaire
[Musique]